okay teach me okay i'm very excited
about this all right
simple easy peasy okay this is got water
i usually don't like to put the water in
it
we'll just throw it all in there yeah
just drink the water
um okay i usually do two scoops after
two i do two scoops these well this is
one you can also do one it depends on
how many protein shakes you like i do
everything like hard and full and
abundant
abundant that's my word for the year
i thought like abundance in everything
meaning not like material you know weird
you know i mean like love and
i feel like abundance has been reserved
for a new agey beautiful realm and i'm
very particular with words like i don't
like the word ambition i'm like ew yeah
it's really well it's not a negative
connotation doesn't it abundantly let's
go buddy
and i don't think abundant is gluttonous
no i do not no no it's not it doesn't
have it doesn't have i can't i mean no
all right so peanut butter
do you go straight into the peanut
butter jar with the spoon or do you give
yourself a reserved like
plat portion no i go i go in yeah me too
i like i put a piece of tape with my
name on it so everyone knows that i have
double triple and
you know quadruple dipped in this jar
also a little trick is that bananas are
high in sugar if you're like if you
wanted just a taste of it i would do
half oh not full but it's fine
okay now spin it this way because and
then here watch you go like power
thank you
and then you have to press it again
[Applause]
you know the other thing is is like i i
feel like
i
true i know what am i why why is true
no no i don't know i don't know you know
what listen
i
i like you know what i would do with
this one if this is how it turned out
oh my god it's delicious by the way
[Applause]
oh my god this is so good okay
um
okay you mentioned something earlier
about
wellness
and like
healthy happy life you know you were
talking about it live life laugh
whatever live laugh love kind of with
the gen z
like i think honestly it's really about
like finding out what works for you
and and and like connecting to yourself
that to me that's what i always say like
you know
all of these like anything that it
represents that i'm doing i want it to
be interchangeable i want it to feel
like people can
create their own things with their
how they like to live their life to me
the number one thing to wellness is
connection it's like the friendships
that you're nurturing and the people
that you're nurturing in your life and
how
we feel supported and i talk about like
especially with this show i'm like i
have
a peace with the fact that so many
people are so different
in our country in our world
where can we find the connection
and not fool ourselves but find it and i
think the word connection has become my
north star for
accepting people i'm so open-hearted
open-minded not judgmental
and there is common ground for people i
think we need it now more than ever it
is it's about connection like people are
so different it's always about building
bridge building that bridge where we
meet on the bridge and and you know and
so and that's a huge part of our
wellness yeah and how we can
connect with people even if we disagree
with people yeah that's i think that's
connect
[Applause]
what today is you're happy and hell
once i've been helped yeah i've never
loved rose and thorne but you know i
don't know why it's just not my favorite
metaphor but like happy and hell what
today what's your happy what's your hell
uh so like
some people would love to like run in
the cold
you know that would be my hell today
okay like running in the cold is not
what i'm into whereas some people are
like that is like what gets me going
that would be something like no i'll
pass
hot like hot yoga would be my happy
which for some people are like uh uh
that's my happy yeah that's my happy so
much yeah like just sweat this morning i
woke up and i was growing up you know
like well what do i do what do i do i
read at night i read a night i love it i
sit in bed i read
i learned i'm so happy to learn about
this from you and i will be ingesting it
and putting that goodness into me and i
do believe in the transference of energy
and i need some kate hudson
in my life and in my body and for my
viewing pleasure
and i read your book and i just i
celebrate you okay okay
to learn more about kate's incredible
company in bloom visit to be in bloom
dot com i feel like i have bloomed so
much
[Music]
you